although I plan to release individual
videos on each of the factions in the
division - there is still so much for
finding out about them every day but
also in the interest of not spoiling too
much of the story this early on this
video is more of an overview of the main
hostile factions you could look at it as
sort of a trailer for some of my future
videos that will be posting over the
coming weeks
[Music]
[Music]
you
the division one was based around the
release of the smallpox virus on Black
Friday and the events that unfolded
while finding the source of the outbreak
and creating a cure seven months have
passed we now find ourselves in
Washington DC
although the virus is still present a
cure has been developed in the objective
for Washington's division agents is more
based around the events after society's
falling apart during the initial phase
of the crisis important personnel such
as President Secretary of Defense and
the Joint Chiefs of Staff were evacuated
the first attacks up to the outbreak
were on the Pentagon the National Mall
and various landmarks following this
thorough riots and the city security
forces were hit hard forcing them to
evacuate the capital supply lines were
cut off and after a few days survivors
was forced to band together into
communities organizing themselves taking
up arms and trying to rebuild but at the
same time other groups that start to
form but these groups will list about
survival and more about taking advantage
of the situation using power and
aggression to raid these communities for
supply and control
the hyenas are similar to the rioters in
the division one they're an
opportunistic group that is taking
advantage of the now lawless land
they're easy to spot usually wearing gas
masks ripped jeans and Simmons
but can we often seem in riot gear to
equipped with light firearms they have a
preference for close combat weapons like
veterans and baseball bats the general
combat skills can be seen as unorganized
and unprofessional they often won't
bottle with using cover instead charge
romantically into battle basically their
plan is to charge in and overwhelm with
numbers the majority of the group seems
to consist of young adults were either
criminals affiliated with gangs before
the outbreak or just taking part in the
widespread anarchy they also appear to
be heavy drug users which could explain
the erratic behavior and willingness to
kill nicely charge them towards enemy
gunfire the hyenas prey on civilian
settlements through violence and
intimidation
led by a Council of gang leaders behind
is come still and destroy anything the
Contras take themselves
these are the survivors of a false
quarantine hell-bent on revenge against
those who brutally imprison them and the
society that stood by and let it happen
their leader believes everyone's guilty
and urges our followers to punish those
involved by spreading sickness and
murdering indiscriminately they're
notorious for the sadistic nature and
cult-like devotion to their cause which
is reflected in the use of suicide
bombers and plane throws Emmeline Shaw
is the cult leader of the outcasts she
is an asymptomatic carrier of the virus
and is focused and driven by revenge and
places priority on destroying anyone who
betrays her she is a charismatic
ruthless manipulator who exploits the
weak earlier on during her time at
Roosevelt Island quarantine Shaw lost
her daughter this was the moment that
motivated her to form the outcasts the
outcasts are quite often compared to the
cleaners in New York due to their
fanatical ideas and homemade
flamethrowers and custom rifles but the
goals are very different the cleaners
wanted to burn away all traces of the
virus to save humanity whereas the
outcasts want to punish society for
leaving them to rot away in the
quarantine disease murder nothing is
off-limits to them as long as they are
spreading the misery
[Music]
after the original pandemic broke out
JTF and washington attempted to control
the spread of the virus by establishing
a quarantine on Roosevelt Island this
job was given to Colonel and Horne
Ridgeway he was to administer the
quarantine and ensure that everything
went to plan after witnessing the
tragedy caused by the virus firsthand
ridgway's started to lose faith in the
JTF stability to save Washington DC it
quickly came to the conclusion that
there was no way they were all going to
survive while on the JTF Ridgeway
deployed his men around the quarantine
and Roosevelt Island blocking all
supplies and allowing the SEC to start
to death as in his eyes the sucker
already did his priority was ensuring
the well-being of his men because of the
state the city was in he was able to
keep us up for a long time before his
superiors found out commanding officers
of the JTF eventually discovered what's
going on and had him imprisoned however
it didn't take long until members of his
unit loyal to him had him freed enricher
eyes eyes had done nothing wrong
according to him he was the only one
with the realistic and viable solution
to the situation with the trail of his
fellow officers filled in with rage and
hate towards the JTF and government as
soon as he got out he had the members of
his former unit captured the JTF
officers they hadn't been present and
had them executed and thus the true sons
were born
bother gate sergeant looks like you got
a ride brewing Lock and Load put it down
just as division agents seem to be
making progress towards to the retaking
of the nation's capital a new enemy
appears the black tusks are an unknown
secret private military organization
they are disciplined and highly
organized easily identified with a black
military attire and technology that's on
power or even superior to the strategic
homeland division they are highly
trained and experienced soldiers using
their drones and robotic war dogs the
black tusk quickly worked through DC
undoing all the work that the division
has achieved missions settlements
strongholds these have all been invaded
by the black tusk they are the greatest
threat division is ever faced and at
this point in time their agenda is
completely unknown there are rumors that
there are group of elite soldiers that
have a long history of working in the
United States government and that their
primary objective is to destroy the
division and take control of Washington
DC
as I said earlier this was just a recap
of what will already be known by a lot
of you but for anyone only just jumping
into the game now the ones that may not
have been a part of all of pre-release
material this may have given you a good
starting point on the hostile factions
of the division - I've kept out any
spoilers that are camp for now as I feel
it's a little early for me to be able to
fully explain some of what's been found
there are also a few other factions have
popped up in Washington DC and I'm
hunting down as much information as I
can both in game and through the
companion novels
we also have a number of characters that
have resurfaced as well some new ones as
I'm sure you can understand it's been
incredibly difficult to pull myself away
from the game to put this video together
but rest assured I'm finding some
interesting information relating to some
of these factions and characters that
are hoped to be able to talk about soon
although on stockpiling a lot of Intel
if you have any interesting fines and
even theories that you may have let me
know the eCos phone recordings and
various other clues that seem to be
popping up daily are on the next tier
can when compared to the Division one
the challenging part is piecing it all
together to make sense of it even though
this video may have been nothing new to
you I hope you enjoyed it and can see
where I'm trying to take my future
videos thanks for watching Cheers
[Music]